ja man jammern 93 punkte mitgebracht und
meinen zu ersten zweifel am sieg auf
tape halleluja ist dabei wir kämpfen
alle meine abonnenten
leute herzlich willkommen zur ersten
runde mit face käme auf es ging ich habe
mir gedacht ich habe sondern eine webcam
der macher ein bisschen facetime base
camp und wir zocken zu war begeistert
ich bock drauf ich hoffe euch gefällt es
auch hat mir die kommentare
ob ihr mehr sehen wollt oder lieber
andere spielmodi und auch welche und es
geht los
magische gutzuschreiben nicht hast du
den typen gefährt dann juni schwere der
wird gebannt alter hast du's gefilmt
keine ahnung ich weiß nicht ich als
europäer rütteln nein eine scheiß halter
alter ist ein echt leute ich denke mir
so wie dumm kann man sein bitten hat ein
bisschen anstand also ich möchte jetzt
nicht meinen abonnenten angehen oder so
aber okay das gibt mir auch mal die
ecken schwert aber ganz ehrlich wenn ihr
so ne scheiße macht er schreibt extra
nicht tagen dann [ __ ] euch einfach in
den arsch es gibt kann ich nicht machen
das ist einfach so dass das ist so wie
im echten leben keine ahnung strich vor
im echten leben steht irgendwie eine
behinderte person am bahngleis in die
shops die einfach drauf weil es lustig
ist das so gefestigt ist genauso als ja
weil die person kann sich nicht wehren
was kann sich auch gegen target nicht
werden und das ist einfach asozial
ganz ehrlich also sorry das jetzt dass
ich jetzt so viel herz schieben muss in
der aufnahme ist halt leider ich war
also ich gefunden die sinne und spaß
wenn es irgend jemand bei mir macht und
dies filme ihr wählt euer leben die band
geklaut
walter ich hab' ich habe vor ihrem alter
ich habe ja wohl ein diamant wird am 1
london alte hits wie west raider oder
bist du ein abonnent ist einfach
ich weiß nicht ich schreibe mir einen
chat derjenige der kran crafter grad
betragen hat rittenband
ups auf video von anderen eltern den
offenen meer wo man nicht irgendwo
runter geguckt werden kann irgendwelchen
kleinen poren sind eltern und spaß es
gibt so viel ich habe so viele coole
abonnenten die hacker normal mit mir
spielen wollen und vielleicht martin
aber dagegen haben wir auch nichts so
schreiben es leider entschuldigt sich
liesi play cool ja was denkst du wenn
ich will natürlich gerät kommen nicht so
dumm
keine ahnung wie das war die gleiche
kleid andere die man keine ahnung hat
einfach cool in den chats so als ob
irgendwas zu bedeuten hätte essen ersten
schreib ich schreib dann soll sich
derjenige dann mal melden
man kann doch jede art von pillen dem
man sieht aber ich war es nicht
dann schreibt ein paar tagen gehört hat
gott schütze unser held aufnahm und spaß
egal vielleicht erst mal spaß ganz
einfach wir haben jetzt mal über diese
sparten die einen am anfang der aufnahme
killen wollen weil es einfach so
erkennen ohne scheiß wollen wir wollen
wir heraus einfach eine eskalation
machen müsse schreibt doch ich schreibe
ich hab's ganz so sagt alter ich habe es
so satt weiß das ist einfach so asozial
ich finde diesen vergleich mit der
behinderten person der zieht einfach
vollkommen und da drin sie jetzt welche
alter ich weiß nicht welche kaputt boxen
einer von ihnen reisen schwert bis zwei
leute
da drin knight rider games trader meter
ich habe leider kein essen ich hab noch
reizen ohne scheiß okay jetzt haben wir
raus was empfiehlst du gerade empfunden
als du geschrieben hast nicht tragen und
diese personen geschrieben hat und die
person die stadt hat ja jetzt wir hier
schon schönes viererteam oder wie ja
okay das ist dann ist es eben eine
kleine torkonto weiter da wird sich
freuen da hinten alter zweierteam gegen
für ging fünfer team
ich bin im film chloe darsteller weiter
habe ein gefällt mir ganz ehrlich es ist
halt zwei games
wir sind schon im dm alter also dem haus
max ist es einfach nicht sein man keine
eskalation aber einfach mal
es ist berechtigt ja dicken husky zu
schieben box mich doch nicht nur und
alter box mich doch nicht wissen in
einem fucking team
die hundezone nadu runde so ein alter
piste sind was warten
nein mit dem schwert labert der von
warte alter aber jorge was geht mit
neuem equipment ab walter richtig krank
sorry leute eigentlich hat sich team
aber ich hab jetzt gerade einfach nur
bock hat irgendwas zu erzählen und
deswegen mal kurz gedient ihr werdet ihr
verzeihen auch dass ich noch nicht oft
in die festgeld schaue ich muss zum
ersten mal
und ja klar wir machen hier ja wie warte
mal was willst du machen auf jeden fall
leute falls ihr das jemals gemacht habt
bitte bitte lass es einfach
bitte lasst es uns wert ermitteln macht
mich damit punkt oder so also tagen
erstmal begriffserklärung gottlieb
lisicki ist ihr alter ich krieg dich aus
deinem leben alter kam er gott es gut
ist gutes tut dies gut die marke gibt
mir okay ich hab sogar abzurücken
puh ging erstmal begriff schon sagen
halten heißt es wenn menschen am anfang
der runde
jemanden schlagen um dann später die
punkte zu kriegen wenn sie sterben oder
so
und am schlimmsten ist das survival
game7 weil hier einfach runter hauen und
vier tagen falls jetzt leute sagen wie
diese lisicki keine ahnung vom leben hat
dass das taten dass man jeden am anfang
töten darf target ist ein
ich sag mal straftatbestand auf jeden
fall das steht unter todesstrafe und und
spaß so leute wie ich also ich bei mir
kriegt man wenn man tötet 100 punkte und
ja bei mir ist hast du dich einfach alle
punkte verdient und dann kommen
irgendwelche menschen an
also ich habe die verdiente spielt ich
habe eine komplette runde gesorgt 15
minuten und im deathmatch gewonnen und
so habe ich mir die punkte verdienen
oder irgendwelche schwer also harten
gegner gekehrt oder so und da kommen
einfach solche leute an die ein am
anfang schlagen und sind einfach geil
auf deine punkte und schafften es auch
noch und spaß solche leute sind einfach
mega abstürzt das ist so als rose scheu
dpa die haben also keine chance wenn du
die mdm triffst dann gehen sie so drauf
ich muss jetzt gegen gersten 4,6 als
willst du dm ich die innenstadt und
sicher zum bett lernen so ein bisschen
geld zusammen ist aber in clustern geld
ja ohne scheiß das ist einfach das ist
einfach man nutzt die hilflosigkeit aus
jetzt schaue ich ob ich meine gut an dem
auslassen kann lässt einfach irgend
welche leute die arbeit machen und wenn
die jungs chillen und passt ja schon
ja man ja man 93 punkte die mir gebracht
und meinen zu ersten zweifel games sieg
auf tape halleluja ist dabei wir klar
von alle meine abonnenten biegler von
alle meine abonnenten blick hält an alle
die tage und damit verbleibe ich so es
gibt ein dickes herzlich selbst von mir
macht's gut leute und ich wieder übrigen
sieben und welche target ja in diesem
sinne hat rein
servus